- Protéger la terre contre
l'éventualité d'un astéroïde
menaçantesesest le but visé
par le programme de protection
planétaire de la NASA.
- On se dit : "C'est peut-être
mieuqu'oqu'oqu'on soit préparés
que pas préparés."
- La Québécoise Julie Bellerose
et la cheffe de navigation
a a a mission DART,
une mission qui vise à tester
un scénario de défense.
JULIE BELLEROSE, ingénieure enan
- Ça, c'est vraiment la première
mission dans le cadre
de défendre la planète
des astéroïdes, des comètes,
des petits corps qui pourraient
venir vers la Terre.
- Après un voyage de neuf mois,
la sonde devrait atteindre
sa cible ce lundi 26 septembre
à 19 h 14, heure de l'Est.
La sonde s'écrasààà une
vitesse de 23 600 km/h
sur un petit astéroïde de 160 m
appelé Dimorphos.
Toutes proportions gardées,
c'est comme si on lançait
une voiturette de golf contre
la pyramide de Khéops.
Le but n'est pas de détruire
l'astéroïde, qui, de to
façon, ne présente aucune menace
pour nous. On vise plutôt
à le dévier de son orbite.
La NASA compte mener d'autres
missions du genre d'ici quelques
années. Elle dispose donc
d'encore beaucoup de temps
pour peaufiner son futur
plan de sauvetage.
- Il n'y a pas d'astéroïdes
en ce moment qui vont frapper
la Terre. Ce n'est pas
impossible, mais en ce moment,
c'est improbable.
- On estime à 99 % les chances
de succès de la mission DART.
Toutefois, on saura seulement
à la mi-octobre si l'astéroïde
a été dévié de son orbite.
Ici Danny Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréa